dan Wolken USA Today national columnist
his most recent column NCAA Board of
Governors opens door to athletes
benefiting from name image and likeness
Wow the NCAA finally got some good
publicity Dan what do you make of all of
this well it's I take a very long
process to get to the final result I
don't think the n-c-double-a can just
kind of flip a switch and say hey now
we're doing name image and likeness they
need to figure out how it's going to
look and the structure and what maybe
some guardrails and controls because as
Mark Emmert said they are not interested
in a model where third-party
endorsements just have kind of free rein
to do what they want and I sort of
understand that from their perspective
but they feel the pressure they
understand the times have changed the
legal challenges or I should say the
legislative challenges that are being
presented in various states and
potentially the US Congress and they
know they have to act but it was
intentionally vague what they did
because the truth is they just don't
know exactly what it's going to look
like and I wonder how do they cap this
because they I just don't know if
they're gonna go hey you know to uh you
can make as much money in Alabama as you
want off your likeness I just don't
think that's going to happen or you know
Lawrence and clam Clemson I you know
conflicts here there there's a lot of
there's a lot of barbed wire in here Dan
yeah I don't think that the issue is so
much to Otago Milo is a huge name now
and he's a star and he can go out and
negotiate all these deals because of how
well-known he is I don't think that's as
big of a challenge for the NCAA as the
recruiting element and that was what
kept coming up and talking with a lot of
people yesterday who were trying to
figure this out on a policy level it's
not so much the name image and likeness
opportunities for current athletes it's
how do you allow that liberalize that
while preventing it from becoming a
situation where
it's just boosters or people who own
businesses and college towns throwing
money at recruits and saying come to
this school that I root for and play for
Alabama
Clemson whoever and we'll give you X
amount of money yeah that's what they
want to try to prevent but how do you do
one without the other it's a really hard
needle to thread and and I'm not sure
how they're gonna figure that out yeah
and I that that's been my big concern
about this from the beginning is if you
know that if I go to that school or that
conference this is what I can make or
they're promising me that I'm going to
make this and therefore you might have
somebody saying yep he's slotted to go
to Arizona Oh nope he's going to LSU
well maybe this is just more aboveboard
because we know it's gone on and you
know a lot of these cases so I'm just
not sure you know I I think a player
should be able to control his likeness I
just get worried that just like you said
the boosters come in and say you know
what I'm if you sign with us we got a
million dollars slated for you to make
over the first two years here and all
you got to do is show up on Sundays at
my car dealership and look I know
there's a lot of people who will be out
there saying well what's wrong with that
and maybe there isn't in a kind of
perfect world there's nothing that it
would be problematic with that but I
think in reality when you're dealing
with 16 17 year old kids high school
recruits you don't know how they're
gonna pan out you know there's a small
group of design williamson's who you
know we're going to come to college and
be awesome they're gonna be stars but
especially in football you know you go
through the rivals lists every year a
lot of these high profile players they
don't pan out and you get a bunch of
guys like you know like Johnny Manziel
was was a three-star recruit he's not a
guy who would have commanded huge money
as a recruit to go to Texas A&M but he
became a big star and because of the way
he played and the way he was perceived
he could generate those opportunities
and I do think it's problematic to put a
16 year old on a call or a 17 year old
of that much money in their hand bring
em on
college campus with all these
expectations boosters who kind of feel
like maybe they own the player like
there's a lot of issues there that that
I can understand why the n-c-double-a
he's got some discomfort with that do
you see a scenario anytime soon in our
lifetime where the NCAA is actually
paying players no I don't think that
that's the way it's going to go down now
look the one thing that they could do
and this is something that Sonny Vaccaro
has has talked about and I understand
the logic behind it which is say the
colleges just said all right we're going
to take all of our money that we get
from television from marketing from
licensing and then we're going to just
cut the athletes and on a percentage you
know based on however many games they
play they get a fixed percentage that
get it maybe after they use up all their
eligibility it's in a trust for them
maybe that kind of thing makes sense the
problem is how do you negotiate what
that percentage is this is not unionized
it's college athletics and you know I
sometimes I think that would be the best
thing for the n-c-double-a is to let the
athletes unionize and then all these
issues can be negotiated collectively
bargained and you don't have to
necessarily have congressional
intervention the way people are talking
about right now but that doesn't seem to
be the road they want to go down but
that's one potential solution is is that
that group licensing money and you just
put it in a pot you cut everyone a check
at the end of their career and and
they're essentially paid for their name
image and likeness I wonder though Dan
down the road and I keep thinking that
maybe you have these power conferences
they secede from the NCAA and therefore
you know who's getting what how much
money let's say the 60 best teams are
here and then you could pay them you
know maybe you have a relegation maybe
somebody does earn the right you know
North Dakota State gets it you know I
don't know but it feels like there's and
maybe seismic is is hyperbole but it
feels like there's a shift that's
happening at some point in college in
college sports certainly in football
well there's a shift in the public
perception there's no doubt there's a
reason why all these politicians who
ever said a word about this for years or
all the sudden chiming in and jumping on
this bandwagon because the public has
has shifted and they feel like it's an
opportunity for them to get a win
you know legislatively that people are
going to support so there's no doubt
that that something has happened but I
think the thing that we kind of need to
remember is it's not like the school's
want to go pay these guys for a variety
of reasons it face to see from the
n-c-double-a it will be because of
something like they could the top 30 or
50 schools could get you know a massive
NFL style television deal and and just
leave everyone else behind but you would
still have a regulatory body that that
oversees all this because Dan the one
thing that I've learned in college
athletics is even the smallest little
rule and policy change the power schools
are not all in agreement
they have vast disagreements because
they all don't trust each other to do
the right thing and and it's a really
interesting dynamic they like the
structure of the NCAA because they like
living within those lines I'll leave you
with this at after his first year at am
what do you think Johnny Manziel would
have been worth his likeness would have
been worth in that area I'm not a
marketing expert but I mean you'd have
to think several hundred thousand
dollars in in national you know whether
it's McDonald's or coca-cola or whoever
I would have thought all the big
companies would have probably wanted to
jump on that bandwagon and we have some
guide you look at what you know kind of
a a mid-level Star NBA player makes in a
shoe deal or whatever is available to
them you know I think that's that's a
guide I don't think it would be tens of
millions of dollars but Johnny Manziel
have made a million dollars after
winning the Heisman no doubt and the
same was I mean Zion would have probably
been worth more right well and Zions an
interesting case because I don't love
the exact number but he had over a
million Instagram followers already
before he
at Foot at Duke and that's something
that they talked about yesterday which
is okay social media there's a huge
opportunity there for a lot of these
guys who have established brands who are
stars in Zion Williamson was a star on
Instagram and and those guys can get
paid and I do think the n-c-double-a is
is is going to find ways to allow that
because that is based on a brand that a
player has built essentially on their
own and that's one I think huge Avenue
for some of these star guys to to come
in and and make a lot of money to play
college sports yeah we got a long way to
go on this Dan always great to talk to
you thank you for joining us so thanks
for having me see you Matt's den wolken
USA Today national columnist for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]